Turning on shadows for a scene is pretty straight forward in 3JS. You enable
the shadow map on the render itself, and tell the spotlight to cast shadows.
For each object you have a choice. You can have it cast or not cast a shadow,
and you can have it receive or not receive shadows from other objects. For
example, if you know a ground plane is never going to cast a shadow, you can
save a little. Processing by not setting the castShadow flag to true for it.
One feature of 3 JS is that you need to set castShadow and receiveShadow for
every piece of geometry. If you have an object3D that contains three meshes,
you need to set the flags for each of the meshes. Setting the flags on the
object3D itself will do nothing. This is actually a constant struggle in seeing
graph systems. What wins? If I set an attribute on a parent and on a child,
does the child setting win over the parent or vise versa. 3JS avoids the issue
by simply not letting the parent have any say. It's tedious to go through every
object and have to set these flags, especially for something such as the
drinking bird. Happily, 3JS has a traversal method you can call that will walk
through an object and all its descendants. Children, grandchildren, and so on,
and do whatever you want with them. Here's the snippet I use. This code sets
the cast and receive shadow flags true on every object that makes up the
drinking bird. It''s actually doing a little bit too much, as setting these
flags on objects without meshes it doesn't do anything, in other words on
parents. Here's a better code. This is some real live Javascript, checking if
an object has a mesh. If it does then the shadow flags have meaning for it, so
we set them. Give it a try now turning on shadows for the spotlight you added
to the drinking bird scene. I've kindly set up the cast and receive shadow
flags for the drinking bird itself, but not for the ground plane. I'm also
leaving it up to you to figure out where the various call to enable shadowing
go. For this exercise I've also added a little sphere representing the light
source in the scene. If you move out you'll see it hanging in the air. Doing
this for your lights is a handy way to get a better sense of where you're
placing them.